you see this penguin this was you when
nen was being explained for the first
time and in fact this penguin is still
most of you when nen comes up in casual
conversation even after finishing hunter
hunter you don't know how nen works but
that's okay because we're gonna sort
this out hello and welcome to the new
order of your source for everything
anime and manga my name is liam and this
is the first time i think i've shown my
face on this channel which you know it
feels a little bit weird but hi but
today we're here to tackle the
infinitely expanding topic of nen so
i've done roughly a gazillion videos on
nen and affinities subtypings all sorts
of crazy crap in the past however i have
yet to make a video explaining why those
videos needed to be made in the first
place nen is not the world's most
beginner-friendly power system to grasp
and throughout the lifespan of hunter
hunter it keeps evolving adding more
layers of complexity with an almost
textbook style of efficiency i would
equate the first explanation of nen to
say being in kindergarten it's all
fairly simple like learning the alphabet
however it does evolve very very rapidly
and by the end of the series new
information about nen is almost like
taking a university course and because
everything keeps building on
pre-existing knowledge if you miss
something in those early or even those
middle days nen can get very very
confusing very very quickly and to
demonstrate this point we're going to
have a quick round of nan quiz a very
simple minigame where i ask you a
multiple choice question about nen and
should you answering correctly then your
punishment will be to subscribe to the
new world review which will also result
in consistent injections of hunter-based
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed meanwhile if you are
correct then you will be crowned king of
the nen people so here's your question
which of the following is not a
subtyping of manipulation a coercive b
counter-coercive c pseudo-coercive or d
solicitation that's right three of these
things are indeed actual things one of
them is not i need you to spot the wrong
one so make your choice now and we shall
reveal the answer in three two one and
bam it was b counter coercive so if you
guessed incorrectly then you know thing
to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a new member
of our association welcome now reason
number the first why nen can be
difficult that's because the first time
it ever comes up in conversation it is
deliberately misexplained when gon and
killua first approach wing during the
heavens arena arc he appears to give
them an explanation of the four basic
principles ten zetsuran and hatsu
however he quite deliberately misleads
gone and killer into a false explanation
because they are not his students the
problem here is that hunter hunter is i
don't know what's the word for it it's a
story that's the word it's a story so
just as gone and killer are misled so
are the audience what wing actually
describes is a concept known as nen of
the flame it's designed to be a mental
exercise to prepare students of the
shingen ryu school of kung fu to learn
the true art form and just become
familiar with some of the vague concepts
which from an in-world perspective i
really really like i think it's pretty
neat that they have this sort of
training step instead of launching
straight into aura control it makes nen
feel like a much more realistic practice
but in terms of being a story it's quite
problematic that nen is explained in two
different ways in quick succession
during hunter hunter because those two
explanations can then become a little
bit muddled for example none of the
flame is described by wing as being a
power that inflames our souls expressed
by the strength of will whereas actual n
is all about manipulating your life
force and is only very loosely connected
to the concept of willpower it's not
like haki in one piece where the
stronger your will the greater your haki
output it's not like that at all but a
lot of people do equate nen to a more
standard shot in practice of whoever has
the most drive to win will generate the
most units of the the win-related
substance aki chakra riatsu ki
the the stuff but it's not an easy thing
to throw out a concept like that and
then retcon it a couple of chapters
later because it is there present in the
minds of the audience and it's not a
great start to nen to be perfectly
honest because this is as simple as nen
will ever be and it's already kind of
confusing another simple factor that
often trips people up is the name itself
nen i encounter a rather surprising
amount of people who believe that nen is
a substance that for example when gon
generates a duncan attack he is fueling
that with nen however nen is not a
substance nen is the name of the art
form what gon is using to fuel a
jejungken is aura they're direct thy
force to equate it to a martial art
think of judo judo is the name of the
study not what you're using to implement
it so when characters in hunter hunter
say that they're using their men think
of that in the same way that a martial
artist would say that they are using
their judo or maybe in the same way that
a cyclist would ride a bike you know you
wouldn't say that a cyclist is riding
their cycling nen simply means the
formal study of aura control and
manipulation with that said i do also
recognize that there are a couple of
occasions where the terms nen and aura
are used interchangeably in hunter
hunter which once again might add a
slight layer of confusion to the basic
principles though we have four of them
three of the four are very
straightforward ten coats the body in
raw aura for defense zetsu suppresses
your aura containing it within your body
and wren is a projection of aura to a
particular target or purpose but where i
find that a fair few people start
tilting their heads and going huh is the
fourth basic principle being hatsu and
this might have to do with the way that
wing demonstrates it which is a simple
projection of aura at a wall thus
breaking it and the way he does it is
almost like using a more tangible form
of ren really however hatsu is a
personal expression of nen which has
another much simpler term being a nen
ability using hatsu and using inability
are essentially the same thing i mean if
you wanted to get super technical and i
guess we do hatsu describes the process
and inevitability describes the result
so to illustrate krapika conjuring his
chains is an application of hatsu he had
to think about and construct the
properties that he wanted to imbue
within the chains as well as any
conditions or restrictions and the
resulting chain is his personal
expression of nen which is now his
inability but with the basics under our
belt a lot of people tend to fall into
the confusion pit when it comes to the
advanced applications and i don't blame
them because we do move through them
pretty quickly the advanced applications
are general abilities that further or
combine two or more basic applications
or even other advanced ones the classic
example of this is a gyo which is simply
a reapplied wren focusing on pouring a
high concentration of aura into and
around the eyes meanwhile something like
n is a direct combination of 10 and ren
but this does get particularly wild with
advanced applications like ko which is a
combination of 10 zetsuren hatsu and gyo
that's right you need all five of those
things just to make this tiny little
power punch and that's also very
confusing because there's a lot of stuff
and also for some reason amongst that
stuff you need to use hatsu as well the
concept of your own personal expression
of nen makes up one of the ingredients
to conjure a generalized advanced
application that anyone can access with
the right training it is legitimately
oxymoronic in nature and if your
attention wanes for a second reading or
watching the greed island arc these
advanced applications will just fly
right over your head and we haven't even
touched on net affinities yet this
wonderful little ring is what many
casual hunter hunt fans will probably
remember most when it comes to nen it
basically dictates what type of natural
or a user you are for example gone is an
enhancer krapik is a conjurer and razer
would be an emitter all very nice and
good but another major misconception i
come across a lot is the idea that once
categorized a nen user can only use
abilities within their affinity that is
100 false but depending on where a
character is placed on the nen ring that
dictates their aptitude for using other
affinities so as an enhancer gone can
use his natural affinity to 100
proficiency but directly on either side
of enhancement is transmutation and
emission which at best gone could only
utilize at eighty percent proficiency
which he does with both paper and
scissors respectively but neither of
those attacks are as powerful as rock
which is his basic enhancement hatsu and
that's because in order to make paper
and scissors work gone either needs to
invest more aura to achieve the
equivalent power or he needs to accept
that those attacks are going to be
weaker with the same aura investment and
it makes all of the sense in the world
it is such a beautifully balanced system
but that doesn't necessarily come across
when you're watching or reading hunter
hunter for like a chill entertaining
experience but that's also why certain
characters are far more impressive than
others isaac network for example he's an
enhancer however his primary ability
involves conjuring and manipulating a
giant golden statue with conjuration and
manipulation being by far netro's least
friendly affinities and while a lot can
be naturally picked up on as you
experience the series there's also a lot
about nen that quite frankly just is not
designed to be consumed in any sort of
entertaining manner quite often in the
series we're subjected to images graphs
or equations that do look like they were
ripped straight out of a textbook so the
concept of nen levels comes to mind
which is just a different method of
explaining the aptitude of the nenring
or perhaps even more excitingly the
profound study of nen reinforcement a
series of equations designed to
calculate the power of strictly
enhancement based attacks or defense
this practice involves attack points
defense points spirit points and even
delightful mystery points and as an
example of such an equation let's say
that we want to work out the statistical
likelihood of a conjurer with an n
limitation being able to block and
enhance his attack like say karapika
blocking guns rock cool so to figure
that out we simply need to follow this
handy guide of dp plus sp times mp minus
ap plus sp doing it all appropriately
within bracket rules and such but then
you get a nifty little numerical answer
that will tell you if karapika could
block the attack successfully or not but
of course that only works if you know
the specific values of all of those
things which is very difficult
especially in the realm of mystery
points i mean it's in the name mystery
so we almost never know these values in
any kind of non-combat situation so look
i do like that this idea exists
theoretically it gives a lot of depth to
the world but the average reader or
watcher just does not need to spend time
trying to fill their brain with all of
these letters and numbers which is
ultimately unimportant to the core story
so the tldr is that people much smarter
than you and i do have a system of
predicting the likelihood of success in
specifically hand-to-hand nan combat and
that's
cool and what makes matters worse for
pretty much all of the above is in my
opinion only having seen the anime my
first experience of hunter hunter was
the 2011 anime and from a narrative
standpoint a few issues aside like kite
and gyro i do think it's a superior
experience to the manga however when it
comes to the technicalities of the world
i have to say that the manga is
everything there's this fantastic thing
you can do in the manga which is if you
don't understand something you can just
not turn the next page you can just stop
and read it again whereas in the anime
it's much more of an ask to stop a video
rewind and watch it again and you're
much more likely to just go with the
flow and instead of taking in the
concept of nan at your own pace of
learning you'll be subjected to the
strict pacing curriculum of the anime
and i do think that you lose a lot in
that experience especially since when
looking back on it the anime is actually
really bad with explaining certain
things one of my favorite examples is
that many non-abilities in hunter hunter
are explained in detail on chapter
covers or bonus materials and a lot of
the time these bits and pieces don't get
included in the anime series and
sometimes those are very big and
important things that get missed like
say crollo skill hunter this does shock
me in retrospect but the anime doesn't
actually tell you what conditions
crawler needs to meet in order to
activate his ability stealing ability
the closest we seem to come is xeno's
vague statement where he goes huh you
must need to do a bunch of things to
make that happen and then crawler thinks
to himself yep i sure do and then we
never find out what the bunch of things
are although i would argue that knowing
those exact conditions aren't necessary
for the story but they are very
necessary to actually further one's
understanding of nen because skill
hunter is far from the only example of
this nun abilities in the anime are
often left vague unexplained and as a
result it only serves to muddle the
concept of nen even further because you
lose grasp of those tangible examples of
exactly how it's implemented however
probably the most confusing thing about
nen of all time is that sometimes it
just doesn't work even if you master the
basics the advance the affinities all of
the crazy sub-classifications and
equations you still won't understand
everything because sometimes nen just
acts in unexplained ways such as biski
to this very day we cannot
satisfactorily explain how her body
transformation works on paper something
like that just simply should not be
possible unless you were a specialist
but she is a confirmed transmuter it
also doesn't help that there are
seemingly natural abilities in hunter
hunter that don't make use of nen or at
least not conscious use of men like
kilwa being able to turn his hands into
claws or the rhythm echo technique stuff
like that or even a creature like nanika
is there wish-granting ability men based
i i think i would make the argument that
it is however trying to explain its
technicalities would be pure and wild
speculation and that's why you don't
understand men even if you manage to
overcome each and every single barrier
to the art form neither you nor i will
ever fully understand it which i suppose
is just part of the wonderful enduring
mystery that is hunter hunter but for
some enduring entertainment here is
another video it's also about hunter
hunter which is the thing that you like
because there's always more to learn
explore and experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there